hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to over curse now the scam
was made just two days for the asylum
game jamming the asylum game jam is a
horror themed game jam for making new
and interesting fun games and I do
appreciate the stranger thing style
intro even though I don't think this
game has anything to do but it
supposedly have stuff to do with the
paranormal / curse thing what can I do
for you finally what kept you there's
some electromagnetic disturbance
probably an evil spirit please do
something
don't worry I'll take care of it I'm on
the job
hello oh hi Rocky I just stepped on you
oh no there you are okay do I need
anything from my car maybe hello
don't mind me just gonna barge into the
house where you called me from okay eyes
met in two days this is actually pretty
cool okay alright so there's something
wrong with all the TVs in the house is
out I'm supposed to be gathering here
somewhere up here maybe like this TV
antenna okay slap that [ __ ] in the shape
and off we go alright TVs seem to be all
in a hundred percent working order
talking head flapping his gums in the
distance that's great okay rocky come on
stranger ways Oh are we making a
stranger thanks reference I do love
stranger things well hi Rocky oh okay
you gonna follow oh there we go okay
rocky there's no ghosts here come on
little boy come on we got it when I was
fun Oh over Chris tink I'm at your home
thank God here's the charlatan I beg
your pardon
oh please I don't believe in your tall
stories but my wife is very super
toothless install your stupid detectors
and go away click okay paranormal
detection plug the detectors to the wall
outlets okay I say oh sorry don't mind
if I throw all my [ __ ] on your floor you
doubting doubter okay hello yeah okay oh
ha oh okay well that's doing this thing
gray I think okay hello hi oh it's
locked
why is it locked okay yeah plug outlet
why okay well I've got some paranormal
powers of my own key nothing else here
alrighty then just gonna barge further
into your home yeah feel free not to
throw show me around don't throw me
around either but you know I'm not picky
okay rocky you stay there
it's a dangerous place around here huh
plug outlet
okay okay all righty then turn the
electricity back it's back here hello
okay and everything's perfectly normal
again well that was easier than I
thought it was okay don't mind my dopey
wok does it go back come on Rocky
don't go running off again come on come
on ball oh it's so cute over curse think
what can I do for you
uh a beast lives in my house please kill
this awful thing and find a way to
remove the bad smells consider it done
okay oh come along Rocky
oh you're so cute deodorant oh you got
into something well alright then that
was easier than I thought it was don't
mind me as I dumped my way up the stairs
won't find another one
Shh alrighty then there's a pantry there
okay goodbye
hello was that the Beast is that the
scurrying Beast okay
okay good boy
[ __ ] is going on here where there's so
many it's my job is to do paranormal
investigation why am i running around
the house as a deodorizer that doesn't
exactly make a lot of sense but you sir
there's something in there so there's
something definitely in the pantry I got
a bear trap with your name on it huh
yeah okay I'll see you see you
oh my god
that rat where it was just a rat that
was the Beast
I'm beginning to think that this is all
a sham I am a charlatan ninh I'm a
charlatan that's making some kind of
money here over curse tank what's your
problem doc doctors hello mysterious
scriptures bedroom clean it's okay I'm
on my way
okey-dokey then clean the marks on the
wall in the bedroom
oh this one's got a castlevania style
feel to it I don't think there's gonna
be a fun adventure I got my cleaning
wait you're rocky meet your boy huh we
your boy huh we God there's something
over here path or no the back door is
locked
well that does not bode well for me I
guess I'm just gonna live with that rock
you belong we'll stay there fine okay
oh yes of course the bedrooms all the
way at the tippy-top II of the play see
Lucy
all right hello good boy no
go back to the car you better not do
nothing to my dog for nothing nothing to
my dog ah hello hi Oh doors locked
oh this is the game we're gonna play
here uh-huh oh here we go oh oh hi
okay then run away but not without my
cleaning spray I've got to finish the
job
oh jeez that rocking chair sure is a
rocking weight I'll go eat I can't go
out oh no I can't go out there okay no
[Applause]
no what [ __ ] [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] oh that's [ __ ] my dog
where did you kill my dog oh you have Oh
okay
oh you [ __ ] gonna get it now
[ __ ] you what are you even what are you
[ __ ] you oh man why did you kill my dog
why did you kill my dog
oh my poor pup oh [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you let's see who else wants some
[ __ ] you alright how about you oh [ __ ]
what WIC what [ __ ] you or your [ __ ] you
double kill any miles in here huh
good boy [ __ ] off kill my dog what else
do I need to do Oh No I've got 13 and 15
oh go back to your car and enjoy your
evening I'm emotionally devastated whose
goddamn ghosts the [ __ ] ghosts on
that's the end oh man
with the fog you can't do that to me my
poor pop oh well for a game that was
made in two days that was really good
it had spooks and that character it had
world building it got me emotionally
attached to a dog and they took the dog
away from me
can't do that I gotta go hug chica
but either way that was over Chris that
was pretty good for what they did in two
days that's actually not bad at all like
they could do a lot of stuff with this
they might be able to expand this I
don't know where and I don't know how
but that was pretty good so but I also
wanted to mention before I go the noon
video today which is supposed to be the
Monday vlog is going to be late but for
good reason
today and this is a big surprise it's
been very hard to contain this until
today but today we are going to be
picking up Bob and Wade from the airport
for a week full of making awesome videos
for you guys I'm just crazy excited
able to see my friends again and it's
been very hard to not tell you guys
about it beforehand but what I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna be vlogging all day long
and then hopefully I'll have another
vlog available later today but hopefully
not too much later afternoon you guys
will see it soon it's just gonna be a
little late and I wanted to let you guys
know about that
so you weren't shocked and appalled when
the video was not there but either way
thank you guys so much for watching let
me know what you thought of over Chris
you can play for yourself down through
the link of the description below and as
always I will see you in the next bye
bye
[Music]